well I thought we were done for the
night but I'm not done for the night we
did the show I did a 30 minute stream uh
or video rather with Kyle kolinsky of
secular talk I took my contacts out I
thought this was it but major major
breaking news in the continuing and
growing Saga involving Donald Trump and
Russia uh I'm going to get to all the
news I will do my best to add the
articles that I'm
citing uh to the description for the
video so people can get them I think
that'll be better than uh pasting them
into the chat Super Chat is on feel free
to start sending super chats about this
or any other topic and I will get to
them as we go also any anybody who signs
up at David pacman.com membership during
the stream live shoutouts and thank yous
forthcoming all of the sort of normal
stuff uh a lot going on a lot going on
so let's begin listen before I get into
the news let's begin with um I I am
having a hard time understanding how
there are still it's not that many
people but there are people who are
writing to me saying David there's no
Russia story period period you might
think that Russian interference didn't
swing the election you might think that
it's not been proven that crimes have
taken place in terms of the coordination
uh uh alleged between Trump in Russia
but how can anyone think nothing is
going on at this point it's very very
weird if someone someone can explain it
to me by all means uh please do so the
latest breaking news is that we now have
us officials with knowledge of at least
one of the investigations going into uh
going on with regard to Donald Trump and
Russia uh that believe that the evidence
now is beyond just circumstantial uh
with regard to the potential
coordination between Trump and Russia
I've added uh a CNN article uh as well
as I will add a political article
article to the uh description for the
live stream which you can check out
let's start with the CNN article and see
if we can make heads or Tales out of
what's going on here uh let me mute the
tab because any number of ads could
start playing at any time here the FBI
has information that indicates
Associates of President Donald Trump
communicated with suspected Russian
operatives to possibly coordinate the
release of information damaging to
Hillary Clinton's campaign us officials
told CNN goes on this is partly what FBI
director James Comey was referring to
when he made the bombshell announcement
Monday before Congress that the FBI is
investigating the Trump campaign's ties
to Russia according to more than one
source let me stop there was James
comey's Revelation that there's an
investigation happening done by the FBI
into possible coordination by Trump and
Russia was that a bombshell to anybody
because it was completely unsurprising
to me and it I I I mentioned this on the
program today if you've been following
what's been going on with Trump and
Russia the last thing you should be is
surprised that the FBI is investigating
the Trump Russia thing because it's
obvious that the FBI should be
investigating it if you believe that
it's always been a trumped up liberal
conspiracy or something right whatever
it is that that the crazy right believes
you also wouldn't have been surprised by
what James Comey said because you would
think it's part of the conspiracy so
although it's being reported as a
bombshell that we now have confirmation
that the president only two months into
his first term uh first and maybe only
term uh is is being investigated by the
FBI for possibly colluding with a
foreign power Scandal of the highest
level it's not really a bombshell
because any reasonable person would have
assumed that that's what the FBI was
doing okay let's go on the FBI is now
reviewing that information which
includes human intelligence travel
business and phone records and accounts
of inperson meetings according to those
us officials the information is raising
the suspicions of FBI Counter
Intelligence investigators that
coordination may have taken place though
officials caution that the information
was not concluded I in that the
investigation is ongoing uh the White
House did not comment and the FBI has
declined to comment uh Johan Spicer
saying and he's right one of the few
things Sean Spicer says that that is
that is correct investigating it and
having proof of it are two different
things a law enforcement official said
that the information in the hands of
investigators suggests quote people
connected to the campaign were in
contact and it appeared they were giving
a thumbs up to release information when
it was ready uh us officials do say to
CNN that it's premat premature to draw
that inference from the information
gathered since it is largely
circumstantial the FBI cannot yet prove
that collusion took place but the
information suggesting collusion is now
a large focus of the investigation at
every step you have a contingent of
people that continue to say nothing to
see here first it was rumors then it was
rumors with named alleges then it was
rumors with named alleges with
circumstantial information then it was
confirmation that that circumstantial
information is at least enough to
Warrant a federal investigation and a
house Intel commedia
investigation uh and now we are going to
the next level does anybody really think
at any point now we're going to just
back up and say whoops it was all wrong
Michael Flynn who resigned in shame for
lying about contact with Russia Jeff
sessions who has not resigned uh uh but
there's plenty of shame I I would
attribute to Jeff sessions uh Jeff
Cher's actions lied about two or
possibly now we know three meetings with
Russian officials Paul manfor confirmed
now to have received millions of dollars
for over a decade millions of dollars
per year for over a decade uh at least
starting more than a decade ago for
spreading a a
protin um sort of influence worldwide
how can anyone look at this and say the
entire thing is fake the entire thing is
ultimately going to be uh uh found to to
not not be a real thing Politico article
which I also have pasted into the
description for the live stream
congressman Adam Schiff the top Democrat
on the house intelligence committee said
Wednesday that there is quote more than
circumstantial evidence now to suggest
that President Donald Trump's campaign
may have colluded with Russia's attempts
to disrupt the election but he would not
offer details quote I can tell you that
the case is more than that to Chuck Todd
on MSN BC and I can't go into the
particulars but there is more than
circumstantial evidence now when Todd
followed up asking if he had quote seen
evidence of collusion collusion shiff
would not say so directly but insisted
that he has seen some evidence that is
not circumstantial again quoting I do
not want to go into specifics but I will
say that there is evidence that is not
circumstantial and is very much worthy
of Investigation so that is what we
ought to do um you cannot believe this
right you can look at this and say ah
still not proof um at a certain point
folks this is going to get to the point
of it's going to to deny that you've
seen proof is going to be that to like
like people that deny that they've
personally seen proof of climate change
right where we have a scientific
consensus but yet people can say hey you
know what I've not personally seen the
effects of it uh it's going to get to
that point it is abundantly clear and
this is a scandal of the highest order
um and then there's sort of another
thing that that is also uh that also
broke today which is the Republican
who's on this house Intel committee for
this Russia investigation Republican
Devon Nunes it's been
revealed that I I don't I mean this is
so complex let me paste this article
also into the description just so
everybody can have uh information I'm
looking at since since we're chatting
about it here and I see we've got um a
lot of comments and we've got super
chats and a whole bunch of stuff going
on which I'm going to get to I'm gonna
sort of summarize what went on with
Devon Nunes Devon Nunes said that he has
evidence that President Trump was
surveilled after all and this goes back
to Donald Trump's claim on Twitter that
Obama wiretapped him something of course
that President Obama doesn't have the
legal authority to do something which
the FBI director James Comey and NSA
director Michael Rogers said on Monday
in a hearing they have no evidence of of
actually having happened uh Devon Nunes
came out and we now are putting together
the timing any reasonable person would
say the reason he came out with this is
that all of this other stuff was about
to explode tonight uh he said he now
believes that there is evidence that
Donald Trump was surveilled uh and what
it actually appears to be i' I've tried
to parse through it and we're going to
get into more detail tomorrow it seems
that there may have been
incidental surveillance of individuals
associated with Trump that happened not
because those Associates were
deliberately and directly being
surveilled but because foreign agents
were being surveilled and by virtue of
having been in contact with them there
may have been incidental resulting
surveillance of trump officials which of
course is damning to Trump if this is in
indeed the story and again the details
are still breaking on this and we're
going to get into this tomorrow um but
that that if I were Devon Nunes and I
was trying to keep Trump safe I would
not be mentioning that he was that in
individuals associated with his campaign
were incidentally surveilled by virtue
of surveillance going on of foreign
powers because that would mean that they
were coordinating with foreign powers
okay so this is absolutely
absolutely crazy and of course it would
not at all vindicate Trump in terms of
his allegations that Obama was
surveilling Trump Tower this is this is
like saying uh well listen I I think
most people get I don't think I need to
to make an analogy here but this is
absolutely and utterly insane what is
going on here uh we're going to continue
following it and and just stunning
revelation after Revelation and what's
abundantly clear now because we've
learned that Republican Devon Nunes from
the house Intel committee he's been
basically running to Trump at the white
house uh if not literally figuratively
to keep him up to date on exactly what's
going on I was asked uh on a stream I
did yesterday or the day before do I
trust that FBI director James Comey is
going to do a full thorough and honest
objective investigation of the Trump
Russia stuff I said no I hope that he
will but I'm not confident um I've also
been asked on social media if I believe
that Devon Nunes is going to conduct a
full and fair and thorough
investigation um and the answer was
always no and now it's abundantly clear
that we need an independent commission
to look into this because you've got the
guy if you're going to conduct a fair
investigation it has to be happening
independent of contact with the the
individual being investigated in this
case Trump and the White House and to
find out that Deon Nunes was running to
the White House to keep Trump apprised
of what it was that that was uh coming
up uh absolute betrayal of trust
absolutely insane and and you know is
America great again yet have have two
months and two days been enough to make
America great again yet and if not tell
me which of the scandals that has
surfaced so far is the precursor to
making America great again all right
that's those are my initial comments on
what's going on and let let me get to um
some of the questions in a super chat
before I do that I I mentioned I would
be doing live thank you to people
signing up for membership memberships
our number one source of funding we
don't receive uh uh big advertising
contracts from huge corporations we've
got a handful of uh advertisers and
otherwise we're mostly funded mostly
funded by um individual memberships and
Demetrios nepas has signed up at
davidpakman.com
membership David richardy as well as
Scott Chisum and uh thanks to to Scott
Scott uh as well as David and Demetrios
we have a coupon code which saves you
40% off of membership we had a major
bonus show we do a bonus show every day
it's an extra show just for our paid
subscribers we do it every day and
yesterday the March 21st bonus show off
the charts ratings are off the charts
because I told what I can only describe
as the St Patrick's Day public urination
story uh so if you sign up whether you
use the coupon code or not I highly
recommend highly recommend uh checking
out the March 21st bonus show let's get
to some of the questions happening in
Super Chat uh $ five Super Chat from
Jerry hickle who says any info on
whether what nunz said today was
criminal or broke any security roles
when he to told Trump details on the
investigation of his campaign no I I
most of what I
said um I just uh most of what I know I
just said rather about the Nunes thing I
don't don't know the legal implications
but you know what Jerry we're going to
be covering this story tomorrow on the
show and I will look into that uh for
you and everybody else in time for
tomorrow's show we've got a $15 Super
Chat from Frank mcwright uh Frank saying
Supreme Court nomination Republicans
blocked Obama's nomination with an
Unwritten rule how is this in any way
legal was it more of just Republicans
not working with Obama feels like
something made up I I would encourage
you Frank to check out the video I did
today which is titled stop Supreme Court
confirmation until Trump Russia
investigation is done there's a few
different aspects to why I believe
democrats should use whatever mechanisms
they have and Republicans may be able to
push it through but democrats should use
every mechanism they have to block the
confirmation of Neil Gorsuch not the
least of which is that once Republicans
destroyed the process by saying oh it's
Obama's last year yeah we're just going
to wait we're we're just not going to
even hold hearings for Merrick Garland
once that was done
Democrats have no duty to just go along
with what Republicans want they should
absolutely object and force Republicans
as as Frank is saying here Unwritten
rule about nominations in the last year
Force Republicans to either try to get
in writing the rule about no nominations
in the last term if they're not willing
to means it can't really be much of a
rule put Meritt Garland up there for
confirmation if he fails then Trump gets
to pick obviously neither are going to
happen Democrat need to do everything
they can to block that nomination uh
I've got another $10 Super Chat from
Frank mcwright uh that I am going to get
to Frank says I just heard you talked
about the Supreme Court issue on the
show I stopped watching to join the chat
but I think it's still a good topic to
go over again okay so I should I
mentioned the video Even though clearly
Frank was watching the video when he
sent the Super Chat and then he actually
suggested I go over it again which I
just did so we we've got sort of like an
Inception situation going on here with
the super chats but thank you to Frank
uh for continuing to support the
show uh in that way very very much
appreciated um okay I I'm I don't know
at this point if we should dig
into what is going on in the minds of
those who believe that there's just
nothing to see here with regard to the
Russia story that that's One Direction I
could go now um I could also talk a
little bit about uh what else is on
tomorrow's show if people want we could
look at more stories related to what's
going on with Russia I'm not uh I'm I'm
sort of I have a bunch of different
directions I can go and I'm glad to uh
uh take direction from the audience in
terms of uh the the direction that that
we should go first a few other thoughts
about next steps with regard to this
Trump Russia thing if you believe that
there's just nothing to see here uh this
is probably going to be pretty boring
for you right because uh you think that
there's nothing to see here and I I
guess I'm genuinely curious what what do
you what do you think all all this is
about I mean you've got countless Trump
officials who have either resigned or or
probably should resign for lying about
contact with Russia why lie about
contact with Russia time and again if
there isn't actually anything to hide I
mean just none of this none of this
makes any any sense um there's a bunch
of other uh stories and and little
details as to the latest claims from
Adam Schiff as well as what's been going
on with Devon Nunes um the uh Casey hunt
Casey hunt from NBC News has sent a
series of very very interesting tweets
that I want to uh sort of call to your
attention Casey hunt tweeted at 4:35
p.m. Eastern earlier today Nunes tells
me he can't show Democratic ranking
membership shift any of the reports
because Nunes slthe committee doesn't
have them in their possession also
tweeting just minutes later Nunes says
he is waiting for an intelligence
Community official to send over the
reports he says he was provided by a
source and this is part of the
constant I guess I would just call it
mounting indication that Devon n as
fundamentally cannot be trusted and you
know what I wanted to give the guy the
benefit of the doubt when I started
seeing his press conferences where he
would come out and he seemed to sort of
be making an effort to um uh conduct a
fair hearing and answer people's
questions he said they would look at all
the evidence he said so far we haven't
seen evidence of Russian collusion with
Trump but we're in the middle of the
investigation I really wanted to give
the guy the benefit of the doubt but it
is abundantly clear now that n cannot be
trusted um it it that there there is
every indication that this move today um
to sort of try to in a clumsy way say he
now has evidence that Trump was
surveilled but really he sort of
inadvertently revealed that that
actually the way in which he claims
Trump was surveilled was incidental
because of foreign surveillance that was
going on if anything it's even more
damning to Trump I mean it's I I don't
even know if Devon Nunes gets it or
understands why his allegation about the
Trump surveillance only suggests that
Trump was really involved Trump when I
say Trump I mean Trump or his team were
involved in in really sketchy stuff I
it's all upside down it's all absolutely
upside down and tomorrow we are going to
be also delving into I mean it's like we
we could do an entire show on Russia
Trump Revelations don't worry I'm not
going to do that to you I'm not going to
do that to you but we could uh it's now
been been revealed and confirmed and I
mentioned this at the beginning of the
stream I'll mention it again Donald
Trump's former campaign manager Paul
manfor was paid Millions he was paid
millions of dollars for helping spread a
u a pro Putin government sort of
attitude or trying to act on the behalf
of Putin's government to improve
conditions for Vladimir Putin and a
couple days ago I I'm I'm not
conspiratorial at all this was just I
wasn't the only I'm not patting myself
on the back with what I'm about to say
this this was being said by many people
um Sean Spicer and others in the Trump
White House started downplaying Paul
maniff for's role saying you know Paul
maniff for he was an adviser didn't
really didn't really have much of a of a
role here and this was Donald Trump's
campaign manager at one point and I and
others speculated that maybe there's
something coming here with regard to
Paul maniff which would explain why
the Trump Administration is trying to
sort of Paul Paul maniford who is that
guy oh yeah I mean barely barely a blip
on the radar they were seemingly
starting to create distance between the
Trump campaign of last year and maniford
because maybe something was going to
break about maniford and indeed it did
um and a memo from Mana for to Oleg der
pasca uh has leaked now it's a disaster
the AP has reported on it just just for
kick so everybody can see uh what source
I'm dealing with here this is the AP
right this isn't some liberal rag um I
will uh put that into the description so
that people can check that out uh okay
Super Chat is open and I am glad to
continue answering questions from Super
Chat of course anybody anybody doesn't
matter who you are doesn't matter how
much you pay doesn't matter if you use
the the coupon code I voted 177 all one
word all lowercase if you sign up for
membership during the stream at David
pacman.com membership I will give you a
live shout out and thank you and that is
exactly what I am doing right now with
Pamela Brooks Pamela Brooks signing up
at davidpakman.com
membership that is exactly what I am
doing now uh with Doug Binet who signed
up at davidpakman.com
membership indeed using the coupon code
I voted 17 we are viewer supported media
the way that we have a studio and vegan
producer Pat or as some now know him
Patrick Constantine Ford or as some now
know him curig Pat call Pat what you
will uh the reason we have Pat and
producer Noah Ferguson and uh everything
that that goes into making the show it's
mostly because of members that sign up
at David pacman.com
membership and I'm going to get back now
to to uh the news but also I saw Diane
Walker zel just signed up using the
coupon code I voted 17 which it saves
you 40% you get 100% of the member
benefits including the bonus show um but
you only pay 60% of the price so that's
pretty good that's uh that's pretty damn
good other stories that we are going to
talk about tomorrow I care a lot about
uh space exploration NASA people know we
cover SpaceX and Elon Musk and plans to
go to Mars Etc I almost did a positive
story about Trump tomorrow I was going
to come to you and say hey guys uh if
Trump does something good as I said on
November 9th that I would do I'm not
going to hide it I'm going to tell you
there's plenty to criticize about Trump
there's no need to hide whether Trump
does something good and I was going to
say Trump did a great thing I read
headlines which told me that Trump has
authorized money for NASA and Mars
exploration and blah blah blah and it
only took getting to probably the second
or third line in most of the articles
about this as well as reading some of
Elon musk's recent comments on Twitter
turns out that actually as Elon Musk
pointed out Donald Trump has basically
reauthorized existing NASA programs the
bill effectively changes nothing about
what NASA's doing existing programs stay
in place there's no added funding for
going to Mars Elon musk completely
correct and by the way this doesn't
actually even provide the funding the
funding comes from Appropriations
committees uh and you know people saying
David why can't you talk about the
positive things that Donald Trump does
there's very few of them and I was all
ready to talk about one tomorrow and
unfortunately it's not a positive thing
and honestly who even knows if Donald
Trump read what he signed or funded the
guy's Clueless the guy's absolutely
clueless uh okay we've got a $5 Super
Chat from Frank mcwright saying that's
for Pat's Duncan Donuts coffee no
hazelnut though yeah we are trying to
put the kibos on Pat going to Dunkin
Donuts and um you know listen this is a
work in progress It's a work in progress
and we're going to keep keep working on
it we have a $2 Super Chat from Andrew
linord who it's I don't see a comment or
question I three I see three white
squares and I don't know if that's some
hidden meaning I hope it's not some kind
of hate symbol or uh the the um symbol
for cuck or Jew cuck but three white
squares from Andrew Linc cour uh with a
$2 Super Chat thank you I uh I
appreciate that tomorrow on the show we
will also be talking about um okay th
this is a story I have to be careful in
how I sort of present this story I am
not someone who so for example example
if you go on on the Alex Jones Infowars
Channel unless something's changed my
belief is currently the position of
infow wars and Alex Jones is that the
Sandy Hook mass shooting was a false
flag attack uh I believe perpetrated by
the Obama Administration as a pretext to
collect people's guns ban guns of course
no guns were banned record gun sales
under Obama a gun sales dropping under
Trump okay so the the motive if indeed
that that was the motive has completely
uh
backfired um so I'm not a false flag guy
but what I want to address tomorrow
is if you
believe in these types of individual
incident false flags on us soil as a
pretext for passing some kind of
legislation or as uh as a way to
distract from scandals Maybe this is a
moment that is ripe for such a false
flag attack and again I'm not saying
that I believe any of these supposed
false flags were false Flags in fact
I've been very clear that they're not
and I've debunked many of them but what
I am telling you is that if there were
ever a moment in politics two months and
two days into a presidency confirmed FBI
and Congressional investigations into
whether you achieved the White House by
colluding with a non-friendly foreign
power Obamacare repeal replacement
explosive disaster I mean totally
abortive explosive disaster we'll see if
we even get a vote on it tomorrow even
if it passes the house it's not passing
the Senate right so if there were a
moment where a White House might want to
you know recognizing that when 911
happened under George W Bush's watch the
country rallied behind him and he
reached I don't remember if it was 88 or
90% approval very very high high level
of approval uh there's evidence from the
past that when there are attacks against
the US uh assuming you don't do
something insane like attack a country
that didn't attack you Iraq instead of
Saudi Arabia um that uh you the country
does rally behind you this moment folks
this moment in time is completely ripe
for a false flag attack as a pretext for
raising your approval rate
I'm not being conspiratorial I'm not
saying that Trump is planning a false
flag attack uh there's evidence that
whether it's Iran or North Korea that
there's an interest in sort of creating
a military intervention under the guise
of National Security which certainly
could be used as a distraction but we're
going to be talking about that tomorrow
okay I I think that this is uh uh
something important to talk about um
okay we've got a $2 Super Chat Super
Chat from jaup thank you very much we've
got a $2 Super Chat from Andrew Linc
cour saying I guess drum emojis don't
come through yeah what if you were
sending Drums by all means I've got my
uh practice snare drum in the background
it did not come through $2 Super Chat
from MV saying thanks for all you do
thank you for watching a
$722 super chat from gamefire 74 saying
how can the US protect itself in the
future from cyber attacks could this
conflict escalate into military action
of some sort uh War as we know it has
changed drastically over the last you
know 150 100 even 50 years and drone
Warfare unarmed aerial vehicles have
changed what war means significantly and
I believe that uh cyber cyber hacking
Cyber attack technology hacking
information Warfare great interview by
the way on our Channel about information
Warfare I encourage you to check out um
I would not be at all
surprised um if in the next I don't know
how long could be 5 years could be 10
could be 20 we saw uh a military
engagement what we would call
colloquially a war that was catalyzed by
a Cyber attack I don't know how the US
can protect itself in the future from
cyber attacks we've got interviews
planned uh with the experts to discuss
that issue uh we've got a $2 Super Chat
from Andrew Lin cour saying my drums are
being censored fake news I would add to
fake news sad low energy exclamation
point $10 Super Chat from David R what
will it honestly take for the American
people to wake up start paying more
attention to Civics rather than reality
TV and demand Trump improve or resign
okay so I I I not often I guess what you
would call
optimistic um about media literacy and
uh people's understanding and engagement
with with what's going on however I am
inspired somewhat positively by the huge
growth that our show has seen and other
Progressive shows since November 8th and
particularly since January 20th I uh
announced uh very early this month that
in February we had
523 new paid subscribers to to our
show for some Outlets maybe that's not a
lot but our previous record for new paid
subscribers in a month was in the low
200s okay so we more than doubled that
uh we had our best month ever on
YouTube in February of 2017 February
being the shortest month being early in
the year it's usually the worst month
advertisers often save their budgets for
the end of the year best month in
history for the David Pacman show on
YouTube best month in history for the
David Pacman show uh on the podcast uh
somewhere around 300,000 downloads of
the one hour podcast in February so to
some degree David I think that what's
going on right now um is waking people
up now yeah there's committed trumpists
who as we've said before Trump could
shoot people on Fifth Avenue they don't
care they're going to stick with Trump
but uh the approval rating of trump
dipping in the Gallop daily tracking
poll to 37 7% a couple of days ago that
tells us that that base that committed
lwi information trumpist base maybe
significantly smaller than the 40
whatever percent of people it was that
voted for Donald Trump on November 8th
so I'm hoping
David uh that we are starting to see
people wake up and I I predict that we
are not too far from people have been
calling for Trump's impeachment and
resignation since before he was even
inaugurated right but I think we're
going to start seeing more serious and
credible calls for impeachment and or
resignation probably within within six
weeks again this is just me charting how
things are going and uh we we will we
will see um I want to say a few more
thank yous to new members that have
signed up at David pacman.com membership
while I've been chatting I will remind
you again the first thing I would do
when you sign up is uh go to the website
go to the member content portal when
you're a member and you're signed in at
the top a new menu item appears which is
member content go to member content 2017
go to March 21st and watch the bonus
show I told what I am describing as the
St Patrick's Day public urination
story uh and PE people are loving it um
lot of emails about that and it all
relates to a an email I posted to my
Instagram account david. Pacman uh on
Sunday by the way if you don't follow me
on Instagram follow me on Instagram I'm
actually doing um I I uh committed to
doing more paintings that painting in
the back is uh some of my earlier work
from 2016 it's pretty atrocious but I
actually um got a painting book and I am
going to be doing a painting soon and it
will appear on my Instagram which is
david. Pacman okay I I got distracted
there uh Jennifer rhods is a new member
at David pacman.com
membership uh Brian curn Brian curn is
also a new member at David pacman.com
membership and Aaron jeromeo Aaron
jeromeo has also signed up using the 40%
discount code we're talking about $3.60
a month if you use the 40% coupon code
or $3 a month if you pay for the entire
year at once okay let me uh what did I
want to get to next here by the way how
many people watching now are uh are in
Europe it it must be very very late at
night in Europe I see uh Nina Lisa
saying it's 3:00 a.m. where she is and
she is up watching the live
stream um who else anybody else oh by
the way but let me just just I I don't
know if I should really be um by the way
should I when I want to be sincere
should I pull my glasses off and and
take a different look I see that that
move done a lot uh I did a 30 minute
video with Kyle kinsky
earlier um and one of the things we
talked about was a vice article which
stated that right-wingers dominate left
Wingers on YouTube and Kyle and I talked
about how the article cited no evidence
and a bunch of other stuff check out the
video Paul Duffy just put a comment that
says Steven Crowder has twice the
subscribers you have LOL listen I I want
to address something real quick let's
let's play a little game okay um
actually I'll just I'll just paste a
link for
you into the chat to to show you
something and this is not a penis siiz
contest okay but if you're going to tell
me as something to make fun of me for
that someone else has a bigger or more
successful YouTube channel than me you
can't go by the number of subscribers
because the way YouTube channels work is
you get paid based on the number of
views right the number of people that
are watching your videos I could have a
million new subscribers right now and it
wouldn't do anything for me unless those
people were watching videos so just for
Just for kicks I'm going to paste a link
into the chat here this is a social
blade link comparing our channel to step
Crowder's Channel and as you can see on
subscribers under rank information and
basic data Stephen Crowder is crushing
us on subscribers if you switch to the
Views tab you might notice that we are
significantly ahead of Stephen Crowder
right Wier uh in terms of people
watching videos right um and you know I
I don't I don't really care I've seen
one video of Steven Crowder's before I
I've accidentally come across videos of
Steven Crowder since people have been
telling me how he's crushing me on
YouTube uh but seriously um if you're
going to make fun of me because someone
else has a bigger YouTube channel at
least point to someone that has a bigger
uh view base because subscribers are not
views okay uh I apologize to people who
don't care about that distraction um and
and we can get back to uh stories we're
looking at for tomorrow possible stories
for tomorrow so I've already sort of
previewed the things that will
definitely be on tomorrow the breaking
news from Adam Schiff and Devon nun as
regarding the Trump Russia investigation
um we're going to talk about what I
thought was going to be a positive story
story about Trump actually a negative
story regarding NASA funding we're going
to talk about the Paul manfor
Revelations I'm looking at uh and the if
there was ever a time for a false flag
attack it would be now story there is so
I don't know if you remember this is
kind of a weird story near the time of
the
inauguration um a story broke that the
Trump Administration wanted like a big
military display reminiscent of Iran or
North Korea tanks and military equipment
Etc and was denied by the Trump
Administration they ultimately came out
and said that's bogus fake news we we
never actually um were were looking at
uh this big military display we didn't
want that emails have now leaked which
confirmed that yes uh uh Trump
transition team officials were asking
for a big military display at least
Donald Trump wanted that so yet again a
story called fake news completely real
news uh also and for the drain the swamp
crowd or the hasht Maga crowd make
America great again um Donald Trump is
filling Pentagon and homeland security
positions with defense
contractors I don't know what Trump
meant by draining the swamp I don't
think his supporters came away believing
that it was going to be former Exxon CEO
as Secretary of State and I definitely
don't think that what they meant was
Pentagon and Homeland security positions
being filled with defense contractors uh
so that's another story that I am uh
looking at for tomorrow I also would
like to and the problem in the era of
trump is we have just you know to too
many stories to cover Donald Trump
promised big spending on infrastructure
which in itself was weird because
Republicans are usually against that but
then he released his budget and his
budget actually Cuts infrastructure
spending overall so it's a sort of
cyclical chain of lies distortions and
and whatever uh so those are some of the
stories I'm looking for tomorrow and of
course 400 a.m tweets from the president
often change everything and completely
Force us to uh restructure our video let
me get to um some of the super chats
that are going on here uh iend D sent a
$2 Super Chat update on hiring someone
for activism organizing so I I addressed
this on a recent live stream we did
recently did a fundraiser we didn't
raise the full amount that we wanted so
we are sort of picking and choosing what
we want to do and what we are going to
um delay doing for the time being one of
the things we're doing as far as the
progressive activism position is we're
going to roll it in to a new hire that
we're in the process of which is a
marketing social media outreach position
so because we didn't raise the full
amount of money that we wanted to raise
it's not going to be a standalone
position but it's going to be integrated
into a new Outreach social media and
marketing position so there's that uh
we've got a $5 Super Chat from Kingsley
djena saying Nina Lisa probably lives on
benefits I have no idea what that means
I genuinely have no clue whatsoever what
uh Kingsley djena is talking about then
going on to say by the way Alex Jones's
op official position is no longer false
flag on the Sandy Hook attacks I believe
Kingsley means he says that the original
statement of a false flag was a
hypothesis all right well uh I guess now
we can trust Alex Jones uh but no I'm
kidding it's good to know what his
current position is five British pound
super chat from stabby
666 maybe Crowder has lower views
because the type of person who
subscribes to him is the type of person
who spends their time trolling other
channels yeah it's possible that Crowder
supporters go and subscribe to his
channel but then come and troll mine and
while they're trolling me by saying that
I'm a jeuk or whatever
uh videos play and they're helping to
increase our view count very very
interesting hypothesis there from uh
from stabby
666 uh okay a couple things on the
YouTube channel I want to draw your
attention to that are interesting and I
would say not right now but maybe once
the stream is over you could check some
of these things out I did a 30 minute
chat with secular talks Kyle kolinsky
earlier today a the video is called
called are left-wing YouTubers getting
dominated you can check that out on our
Channel I think you'll find it
interesting always good to chat with
Kyle we also have a story I teased
yesterday on uh the YouTube channel it's
live right now the title is uhoh Fox
News caught scripting this debate and
what we found in looking at a video of a
so-called debate between um Lisa booth
and Simon Rosenberg during The Happening
Now program on Fox news is that the
things that Lisa boo was saying in a in
an ostensibly unscripted debate were
showing up on the screen on the graphics
as or before she was saying them and
based on my understanding of time I
don't know how that's possible unless
this is not really a debate but rather
script reading of debat likee talking
points and that would be odd to say the
least okay so I encourage you to check
out that video uh once the stream is
over big thank yous big thank yous to uh
John Hall I don't know if I mentioned
John Hall before but John Hall has
signed up at davidpakman.com membership
Shan wcky Shan wcky using the coupon
code I voted 17 to become a David Pacman
show member thank you Sean and Mark R
Mark rup who has also used the coupon
code I voted
17 uh to sign up for membership okay uh
we are moving right into preparing
tomorrow's show so on that note I'm
going to wrap up tonight and we will
talk to you on the program tomorrow
thanks to everybody who watched follow
me on Instagram my new painting that
will be hopefully better than this one
will be posted to Instagram uh very very
soon